Watchmen season 1 was an incredible
journey that spans over a hundred years
and if you're anything like me you might
have found yourself scratching your head
as to when certain events occurred with
the use of flashbacks and episodes that
look at events from a different
characters perspective it's easy to get
lost so in this video we're gonna
chronologically break down the show's
major events starting from the earliest
in the 1890s all the way up to present
day we'll even go over those Ozymandias
flashbacks and see how they fit in with
the other events of the show or earliest
entries deal with the births of some
important characters starting in 1891
Louisiana with Obie Williams
he's will Reeves father and angela's
great-grandfather he'll later end up
moving to Tulsa and marrying a woman by
the name of Ruth Robison who becomes the
pianist at the dreamland theater
fast forward to 1908 where we have the
birth of Nelson Forrest Gardner aka
Captain metropolis and founding member
of the Minutemen six years later will
Reeves is born in 1914 Tulsa by 1918
Obie Williams is shipped off to France
to fight in World War one it's here that
he keeps hold of a German propaganda
flyer made to dissuade the African
American forces from fighting against
the Germans considering how poorly
they're treated by their country he
keeps this flyer which will later takes
and holds on to for over a hundred years
in may 1921 the dreamland theatre
premieres the bass Reeves film trust in
the law the same film young will watch
as a week later on May 31st during the
Tulsa massacre a real-life event which
saw according to a 2001 state commission
anywhere from 30 to 300 deaths over a
two-day period August 14 1929 sees the
birth of John Osterman in Germany the
man who will later become dr. Manhattan
seven years later in 1936 he and his
Jewish father fearing persecution in
Germany flee to England where we meet
the inspiration for Phillips and miss
Cruikshank's at their Manor this refuge
will later become a huge influence in
Manhattan's creation of life on Europa
1938 is a big year for will Reeves he
graduates from police academy in New
York and seeing the injustice around him
takes matters into his own hand by
creating the fur
masked vigilante hooded justice it's
here we learn of the white supremacist
group called Cyclops which predates the
7th cavalry hooded justice takes a bunch
of them down garnering the attention of
Nelson Gardiner who he will later have
an affair with in the television show
American hero story hooded justice is
depicted as being a white male and
saving the grocery store from robbers
whereas the real version sees hooded
justice fleeing through the window after
taking down a bunch of Klan members in
1939 captain metropolis forms the
Minutemen a group of masked vigilantes
which includes hooded justice as one of
its founding members in July of this
year Adrian Veidt is born in New York
the son of German immigrants in the
early 1940s we have the birth of Marcus
a bar Angela's father we don't have an
exact year of birth but we do see him as
a child in the year 1947 which is the
year the secret life of walter mitty
plays at the theater which hypnotizes
all its black patrons it's this year
that June wills wife leaves him and
takes Marcus to Tulsa as wills obsession
with hooded justice has taken too much
toll on the family 1949 sees the birth
of Laurie Blake the daughter of Edward
Blake the comedian and Sally Jupiter
both original members of the Minutemen
49 also happens to be the year the
Minutemen disbands according to PETA
pedia for reasons which includes tragedy
acrimony and other factors
Judd Crawford was also born in this year
1955 sees the body of Rolf Muller wash
ashore the man the world believes to be
hooded justice just three years later
Adrian Veidt adopts the guise of
Ozymandias and will later work for the
next few decades alongside dr. Manhattan
the comedian Laurie Blake Nite Owl and
Rorschach as part of the Watchmen
although not depicted in the show August
1959 sees the birth of dr. Manhattan
when Jon Osterman is locked in the
intrinsic field generator and blasted
with atomic energy the Vietnam War
particularly 1971 sees two interesting
events Judd serves under Robert Muller
in Vietnam yes the Robert Muller who led
the FBI investigation into Russian
meddling in the 2016 presidential
election it's here we also learned from
PDP dia that bien
i lady trues mother had a run-in with
Edward Blake who it's highly intimated
burned down her village 1974 sees the
death of captain metropolis in a tragic
car accident his head was decapitated
but it was never found a year later in
75 will Reeves receives captain
metropolis fortune as consolation for
how he was treated by him in the 30s and
40s it's here also that Adrian Veidt
gives up being a vigilante and reveals
his identity to the public 1976 sees the
birth of both Angela a bar and Calvin
Jelani Calvin's body will later become
the form we see dr. Manhattan in for the
majority of the show in 1977 the u.s.
passes the Keene Act making civilian
vigilantism illegal it also happens to
be the year sister Knight is released
one year later in 1978 the Vietnam War
is over and Vietnam becomes the 51st
state 1979 Adrienne creates the Tachyon
ring he'll later give to Manhattan 30
years later 1985 sees the main events of
the Watchmen comic unfold on October
19th Manhattan abandons Earth for Europa
on the 31st of that month Laurie Blake
and dan dreiberg rescue war shack from
prison only for him to go missing the
next day November 1st
Adrienne records his video to future
president Robert Redford in his
Antarctic lab well beyond inseminates
herself with Adrienne seaman the next
day on November 2nd the dimensional
incursion event occurs the giant squid
attack devised by Adrienne to unite the
world against a common enemy
it's here we also see part of
looking-glasses origin story as he
witnessed the event firsthand at the
beginning of episode 5 nine months later
in August of 1986 the smartest woman in
the world a lady true is born and a year
after that in 87 an 11 year old Angela a
bar witnesses the death of her parents
via terrorist attack in Saigon sometime
later she's met by her grandmother Jun
who wants to take her back home to Tulsa
but she dies of a heart attack before
that can happen
leaving Angela and Saigon where she'll
later take after her grandfather by
becoming a police officer 1992 sees the
election of president Redford winning
over Richard Nixon who had held office
for 24
years his campaign was largely financed
by Adrian Veidt in 1993 President
Redford will receive Adrian's video
informing him that the 1985 squid attack
was a hoax it's Adrian's hope that he
and Redford can work together to make
the world a better place
Laurie Blake and dan dreiberg find
themselves in hot water in 1995 when
they're arrested for violating the Keene
Act an arrest which lands Dan in jail
and Laurie having to work for the FBI's
anti-vigilante task force in the year
2000 at the age of 15 lady Tru graduates
from University with PhDs and
astrophysics nuclear fission
bioengineering and nanotechnology the
drug however nostalgia was previously
the name of adrian veidt's cosmetics
line that dates back to the 70s
nostalgia would later be banned after
widespread misuse and addiction this is
also the last year Adrian Veidt was seen
in public before he retreated to Karnak
this is also the rough estimate of where
young Deanne was born the clone and we
don't exactly know how BN was cloned if
it was a normal birth or maybe some sort
of device this could affect the accuracy
of this date in 2008 Johnny Cochran the
same man who defended OJ Simpson fights
for reparations or as they've been
deemed in the show
Redford ations these are tax breaks for
African Americans affected by the Tulsa
massacre 2008 also sees lady true
visiting Adrienne and Antarctica to tell
him she's his daughter and to ask for
forty two billion dollars to fund her
quantum centrifuge a device that could
be used to transfer dr. Manhattan's
power to her this request is denied by
Adrienne 2009 as the Year adult Angela
meets dr. Manhattan at a bar in Saigon
on the 20th anniversary of her parents
death six months after they meet they
get in a fight a fight which Manhattan
predicted which sends Manhattan looking
for help from Adrian Manhattan wants to
be more human so Adrian gives him the
Tachyon ring which allows him to forget
he has powers in return Manhattan sends
him to Europa where he can be a god and
live in peace but before Manhattan
absorbs the ring he visits will Reeves
who now lives in captain metropolis is
home and divulges his entire plan for
the next ten years up
plan that will shape all the events
going forward with plans now in motion
angela places the ring in Manhattan's
forehead essentially giving him amnesia
and they venture to Tulsa to start a new
life together
2010 sees lady true launching Voyager
probes into space the same type of probe
that Adrienne will later come into
contact with on Europa it's here we
begin the Adrienne saga every episode of
Watchmen with the exception of episode 6
features a segment of Adrienne's life on
Europa each of them spaced one year
apart judging by the anniversary candles
we see on his cakes the first year is
basically an introduction to his life
here he rides his horse writes a play
eats a cake and is also given a
horseshoe which is a setup for his
eventual escape nine episodes later 2011
is year two on Europa Phillips and
Crookshanks perform a play about dr.
Manhattan which Adrienne wrote over the
past year 2012 is year three where
Adrienne catapults Phillips outside the
sphere he kills one of the Buffalo and
receives a stern warning from the game
warden not to disobey his rules this is
also the year back on earth that
Adrienne is officially declared missing
2013 is year four and were introduced to
the fetus lake in that machine that
turns them into adult versions of
Phillips and Crookshanks your 5 Adrienne
launches himself from the catapult and
creates the save me daughter message
which will later be sent back to lady
true who sends a spacecraft to retrieve
him year 6 is not too kind to Adrienne
as he's sentenced to jail for his crime
of leaving the boundaries of Europa 2016
is year 7 in a special scene in the end
credits of the episode Adrienne is given
a cake with seven candles in it
celebrating his seven years on Europa
this cake will include a horseshoe he
will use to dig himself out when this
space pod eventually arrives on earth
December 25th of this year marks the
white night a night in which members of
the seventh Cavalry took up arms against
the police force this is also the night
Angela's saved by dr. Manhattan and the
night were one of senator Keens cavalry
members is teleported to Gila flats New
Mexico this event alerts keen that
Manhattan who's the only one who can
teleport others is somewhere in Tulsa
and sets in motion his plan to transfer
Manhattan's powers to himself the white
knight is a
so the catalyst for Angela becoming
sister night 2017 marks Adrienne's
escape which coincidentally lines up
with the year lady true takes over Veidt
enterprises he begins his two-year long
journey in cryo back to earth it's here
the defense of policeman Act is passed
which sees officers having to mask up to
keep their anonymity a direct result of
the white night in 2018 Judd becomes the
Tulsa PD chief of police and it's around
this time according to a 2018 PD PD
article that groundbreaking on the
Millennium clock begins now we have
September 2019 where the main events of
the show take place I won't go over all
of them since I have detailed episodic
breakdowns for each episode you should
really check out but it ends in late
September with trues demise Manhattan
nowhere to be found in Angela about to
see if she can walk on water the last
entry is October 2019 and it can only be
found on PDP dia it informs us that
agent Dale PD has been fired from the
FBI as he refused to return to
Washington preferring to stay in Tulsa
to uncover the deaths of lady true and
Senator Kean in this piece it's heavily
implied that PD is a Lube man now if you
haven't seen my Watchmen season 1 ending
explain please go check it out and make
sure to give this video a like and leave
your thoughts in the comments below if
the show's back for season 2 I hope to
expand on this timeline as new entries
get added check out my Twitter at think
story whitey and until next time
remember daddy loves you very much